hi I'm Pamela Bhattacharya and I'll talk
to you about our project calendar dot
health a virtual scheduling assistant
that started at Microsoft fuse labs and
was transferred tech transferred to the
outlook team
[Music]
research shows that on average an
information worker spends about five
hours every week scheduling meetings and
when a survey went out to you know
thousands of information workers asking
what are the tasks they want to delegate
if they could to an assistant excuse me
the number one task that people said
they were interested to have an
assistant for that you know they can
offload the task was scheduling meetings
so why why do people want to offload the
task of scheduling meetings to assistant
you don't want to do the back-and-forth
you don't want people remind people to
respond you can you might need to
reschedule a meeting canceled a meeting
there can be updates you can add people
with those people so on and so forth and
it can get very complicated rather what
you want is you want to spend your time
on things that matter focus on things
that needs your attention rather than
you know going all this back and forth
with different people and executives
mostly have EAS to help them with this
task what we want to do is make this
available for anybody so what
essentially happens in a scenario where
somebody has an admin that takes care of
their scheduling they'll have a email
thread going on and at some point please
excuse me when they want to schedule a
meeting they'll just see see their admin
saying that hey can you find a time that
works for us now what the admin does the
admin will look up the calendar of the
organizer and email back the invitee in
this case cat saying that hey Rebecca is
available these times does any of this
work for you and
then cat will respond back and she might
say yes that works no that doesn't work
here is another alternate time that I am
available and all this back and forth
goes on until you know there is a
consensus and then the admin sends out
the ICS are the meeting invite to both
of both the organizer and the invite
this becomes really complicated when the
number of attendees increases you have
to go back and forth with each of one of
them to get consensus in case of
rescheduling you have to start over
again you might need to cancel the
meeting we also you also need to support
resource booking especially in
Enterprise scenarios like conference
room booking human assistant can support
personalization which is you know for
different meeting types
what are times that you preferred so for
example is your lunch time between 11:00
to noon or noon to 1:00 you know for
every people it differs so you you know
you're human assistant learns over time
what are your preferences for different
meeting types reaching your time
consensus so the assistant has to make
sure that you know they go back and
forth with all the invitees they remind
them to respond and get to a meeting
time as soon as possible
and last but not the least the admin and
human admin is able to provide
personalization to this record times
they recommend so you know the organizer
might have a lot of free space on their
calendar but a human assistant won't
just pick any random slot they would
know okay mornings are times when the
organizer wants to focus and get work
done so they only prefer meetings in the
afternoons when the meet will say at a
different time zone they prefer early
mornings over evenings so on and so
forth so all these you know different
aspects of scheduling that a human
assistant brings on board how can we
have a digital assistant does does the
same thing
so we built calendar dot health which is
a scheduling assistant that helps you do
that in an email conversation so say if
you are having an email conversation
with a colleague or a friend and you
need to meet you essentially CC the bot
and the bot takes it flow over from
there
in order to solve this problem we have
three key research challenges that we
have worked on and we are continuing to
work on the first one is the natural
language processing and understanding to
detect scheduling information from these
email threads right there are not only
the first email thread where you see see
your admin and say make take care of
this meeting but all the eventual back
and forth from the invitees you know the
times that we're first on the calendar
doesn't work anymore so on and so forth
so that's that's really the number one
and what what kind of things do you
expect to say to this bot you know
Cortana that can understand you can say
simple things like you know schedule a
call next week or find an hour and book
a room or you can say very complicated
things like next week except Monday or
one of the invitees is optional or
booked a room with a euro scoped
conference room query as we call it in
building 32 so you have to so that
assistant has to disambiguate what is
building 30 to mean so on and so forth
and then understanding intent as I was
you know mentioning earlier you can have
emails back and forth and for each of
them you need to understand the intent
what is the person that you're receiving
the email from asking for and what
actions do you need to take once you
have an email you also need to extract
the relevant entities right with Skott
that are relevant to the context of
scheduling the meeting so if I say it
was great seeing you in New York last
month let's meet up in Seattle next week
New York is not relevant anymore now
what is relevant is Seattle because
that's where we want to have the meeting
and that's where you want the assistant
schedule the meeting for the third and
the most important part of this is
contextual understanding so if there
could be multi-ton conversations with
the assistant so you need to the
assistant needs to remember the
conversation that has happened you know
references to things that are in a
different email thread but related to
the same meeting how do you disambiguate
those the second part the second
research challenge is personalized
personalization or scheduling
intelligence as I talked earlier how do
you find the right time for the right
meeting how do you prioritize meeting
how do you understand which meetings can
be rescheduled which cannot be which
meetings might need to be cancelled so
on and so forth
and the last part excuse me
the last part is the human-computer
interaction how do you build a trust
with your assistant you know how can you
make sure that you delegate your meeting
and then you can be rest assured it will
be in your calendar in due time and in
order to build this trust and build this
expectation we introduce the sconces
framework that we are starting to
experiment with which is automation
levels of a digital assistant so
synonymous to cell driving car
automation levels we are introducing a
concept of digital assistant levels so
level zero is something manual where the
organizer is in complete control of
their calendar which is you know a very
common scenario today level one is you
know smart on-demand assistants so you
just you know ask for things that are
synchronous non-ambiguous you know very
simple to understand the level two is
the delegated support and that's where
we think we are today where you can
delegate it's an ambiguous a synchronous
operation and you expect the assistant
to do whatever it takes to for that task
level three is hands of assistant so the
assistant is more proactive in going you
don't have to explicitly ask for tasks
or scheduling meetings are we scheduling
so on and so forth
level four is personalized optimization
so imagine executives who have admins
that takes care of their calendar you
know making sure they are saving most of
their time they are prioritizing
meetings they can move around meetings
so on and so forth and lastly how can
you achieve the same thing at the
organizational level so you know imagine
you know if the calendar there is this
assistant that takes care of all
calendars that are in an organization
and helping everybody save time find
more focus time so on and so forth so as
we said you know we feel like we are at
a level to where we are giving more
delegated support and with new features
we want to see how we're in the levels
we fall you know some live one thing to
keep in mind that these levels are not
linear as you go from one level to
another it's really hard to get things
going so with that let me show you a
real demo of how this works
so here I am having an email thread
where I Ament someone saying that hey I
am done with the analysis please take a
look and they reply back saying great do
you want to meet and child so I say sure
let me ask my assistant to find some
time for us and I go ahead and now see
see this assistant which is really an
email address Cortana and calendar not
hell and what I do is I give specific
instruction I say katana please schedule
an online meeting for 45 minutes
sometime next week
and I mentioned that the invitee is in a
different time zone so I am in PST I
mentioned that the invitee is in EST
let's see what happens next
so I get back an email from the system
immediately saying that hey I am working
on scheduling your meetings keep an eye
out I'll send you information as things
progress I will keep keep an eye out as
things progress and once once katana or
the assistant is able to get this
information they process it and now they
send me back an email saying that hey
this is no need to reply I'm just
letting you know that these are the
times I proposed for the meeting right
and now these are the times that were
sent to the inviting and once the
invitee response to that the systems
will again process that response so in
this case the next email I find from
katana is saying that hey I propose two
new times to the inviting and I'm
wondering why did katana do that so at
that point I can go to the meeting
details page so in this case this is my
meeting details page so I see that I had
sent so you can see all the messages
relevant to that ladies you can see that
katana had to first proposed this time
to the invitee
and the invitee replied saying that hey
they are not available at the time and
proposed an alternate time range and in
this case they said the week after this
is where the contextual reference part I
was mentioning about earlier so the week
after of what so in order to understand
that we need to in order to understand
that we need to know that the original
meeting time was next week so once it
has this new proposal from the invitee
katana is able to understand that and
propose new times for the week after and
then when the invite you replies saying
that hey all of those times work for me
katana just goes and since I had the ICS
or the meeting object to both the
organizer and the attendee and then for
any subsequent changes to the meeting
you can just reply again with katana CC
and saying that hey I want to reschedule
my meeting and you can give specific
references or you can just leave it
ambiguous and katana will find a time
for you to reschedule the meeting you
can also say cancel the meeting I don't
need the meeting anymore or you know add
this inviting you remove this invitee
mark this invite you as optional
anything that you would do with a human
assistant essentially you can just do by
CC in katana at calendar don't help and
mentioning your preferences in natural
language in even